hello family I'm Jill morone we welcome
you to another 3an today Bible Q&A I
love this program because we have the
opportunity to open up the word of God
to study for ourselves to see what God's
word says and then how we can
incorporate that into our hearts and
into our lives you know Hebrews
4:12 Paul tells us the word of God is
living and Powerful quick and Powerful
sharper than any two-edged sword and it
pierces even to the dividing aund of
Soul and Spirit and joints and Marrow
and it's a discerner of the thoughts and
intents of the heart so when we study
the word it's not just head knowledge
it's to go into our heart it's to change
us through the power of the Holy Spirit
we're so glad you tuned in we're taking
your Bible questions um and we're so
thankful to do that I want to introduce
our family here um around the island
Professor Daniel paren so glad you're
here brother hello I'm happy to be here
because
we get to look at the word of God and I
love studying the Bible in the morning I
love looking at it through the day and
in the evening and I pray that everybody
who listens has that same Joy too amen
that's wonderful uh Pastor John deny so
glad you're here too it's a blessing to
be here this is a great program because
uh people ask questions that I have
never thought of and it makes you dig
and learn more from the Lord amen that's
right I think it's in exhausting you
know what I'm saying like for eternity
we'll be learning and grow growing
learning more of the character of our
heavenly father and um more in his words
so I want to tell you if you would like
to send in your questions we won't
answer them today but on an upcoming
Bible Q&A there's several ways that you
can do that you can pick up your cell
phone and you can text us that number is
618 228
3975 that's 618 228
3975 you can go to Instagram we have an
Instagram account our Instagram handle
is 3 3n uncore official so that's 3abn
uncore official or you can send us an
email on your computer or on your phone
you can do emails on your phone that
email address is Bible QA 3abn TV that's
Bible QA 3ab
bn. we have some incredible questions
today we want to jump right in and
answer them but before we open up the
word of God we want to go to God in
prayer and ask for the Holy Spirit to
open up our minds and hearts to receive
and Daniel would you pray for us yes our
loving Heavenly Father Lord we commit
ourselves to you 100% right now and we
ask for your Holy Spirit to fill us and
guide us each one here at this table
everyone who is listening and watching
wherever they may be this is not our
program it is yours it is not our word
it is yours and we are thankful for that
so we ask for your presence here in
jesus' name amen amen amen thank you so
much uh Pastor Johnny the first
question's coming to you here this one
came in from Ed from Maryland he sent it
in via email is there a Bible text that
says Satan broke God's ten commandments
which caused the war in heaven and is
there a Bible text that says we must
obey God's ten commandments when we get
to heaven very good thank you so much Ed
um I first point you to James chapter
2:10 it helps us understand something
very important it says for whosoever
shall keep the whole law and yet offend
in one point he is guilty of all so in
disobeying once Lucifer that eventually
became Satan would be disobeying or
breaking all of God's ten commandments
let's go to Isaiah chapter
14 and begin in verse 12 to get a
picture of Lucifer falling how art thou
fallen from Heaven oh Lucifer son of the
morning how art thou cut down to the
ground which did weaken the Nations for
thou Hast said in thine heart I will
Ascend into heaven I will exalt my
throne above the stars of God I will sit
also upon the Mount of the congregation
in the sides of the north I will Ascend
above the heights of the clouds I will
be like the most high so we here we have
Lucifer the angel that fell uh coveting
the throne and actually wanting to push
God aside and take over in in essence
wanting worship for himself and the
Bible says you should only worship God
our creator so here he it coveted so
this is a Breaking of God's commandment
and in breaking one he broke them all
let's move to Ezekiel chapter 28 and
begin in verse 15 Ezekiel
28:15 notice what it says Thou was
perfect in thy ways from the day that
thou was created till iniquity was found
in thee this verse is very interesting
because God created Lucifer perfect
there was no defect whatsoever in
Lucifer but Lucifer had freedom of
choice just as God gives to all of his
creatures Freedom of Choice he chose to
sin and that's when iniquity is found in
him by the multitude of thy Merchant
verse 16 they have filled the midst of
thee with violence and thou has sinned
so here we have uh clearly saying that
he has said therefore I will cast thee
out as profane out of the Mountain of
God and I will destroy thee a covering
cherub from the midst of the stones of
fire verse 17 your heart thine heart was
lifted up because of thy Beauty thou has
corrupted thy wisdom by reason of thy
brightness I will cast thee to the
ground I will lay thee before kings that
they may behold holy so here we have
again uh his heart was lifted up uh here
we have pride uh surfacing in him and in
John chapter 8 ver 44 Jesus makes these
uh declarations ye are talking to the
the scribes and the Pharisees ye are of
your father the devil and the lust of
your father ye will do he was a murderer
from the
beginning and Abode not in the truth
because there is no truth within him
when he speaks a lie he speaks of his
own for he is a liar and the father of
it so all of these scriptures help us to
understand that uh Lucifer s broke the
Ten Commandments you have a second
question and give me a moment here it is
is there a Bible text that says we must
obey God s Commandments when we go to
heaven so I began to answer your
question with some questions to examine
the logic will it be okay to kill in
heaven well the answer is obviously no
will it be okay to murder in heaven the
answer is obviously no well how about if
you get some idols and worship those in
heaven you see though that's is the
logic tells you that yes we will keep
God's commandment and notice Isaiah
66:22 and 23 for as the new heavens and
the new Earth which which I will make
shall remain before me sayeth the Lord
so shall your seed and your name remain
and it shall come to pass that from one
new moon to another and from one Sabbath
to another shall All Flesh come to
worship before me say sayith the Lord
you can continue reading but it's
talking about keeping God's fourth
Commandment about uh keeping the Sabbath
day holy and so yes we will be keeping
God's commandment in heaven amen blessed
are those who do his Commandments that
they may have right to the tree of life
and enter into the gates into the city
amen thank you Pastor Johnny uh
Professor parin we're coming to you here
and you know Romans um 6:23 says the
wages of sin is death but the gift of
God is eternal life so as we are all
guilty under the law all break those Ten
Commandments we all suffer the
consequences of death however we can
repent we can choose Jesus and don't
have to suffer that consequence but this
question from Australia came from
Instagram has to do with those
consequences of those who receive God's
Gift of Salvation in Luke 12:
47-48 Jesus refers to the consequence
for those who will not join him in
heaven I recently heard a pastor say
that these verses refer to varying
degrees of punishment for those in this
position it was then said that Hitler
would suffer more than those of lesser
crimes my understanding is the ultimate
consequence is the final death and
eternal separation from God Is it true
that there will be varying degrees of
punishment and do we know to what extent
okay all right behind this great
question is another question which is is
God Fair will God treat us fairly deal
with us fairly and so let's look at this
which is actually a Parable that Jesus
tells in Luke 12 and we just this is not
the whole Parable but just these two
verses that were mentioned verse 47 and
48 and that servant who knew his
master's will and did not prepare
himself or do according to his will
shall be beaten with many stripes but he
who did not know yet committed things
deserving of Stripes shall be beaten
with few for everyone to whom much is
given from him much will be required and
to whom much has been committed from him
they will ask for more so notice that in
this Parable it's focusing on those who
have much light compared with those who
have little light so there is a
difference here between willful
Disobedience and then Disobedience and
ignorance those who know and those who
do not do not know uh think of an
example here where you have the ring
leader of the crime uh the crime Circle
and he at least this is way our just
system should work should get a harsher
penalty than the the little duped
teenager who acts as the the lookout for
the criminals at least you recognize one
should get a punishment that is harsher
than the other but even those who
disobey an apparent ignorance will still
receive the consequence that comes from
sin because ignorance still is not an
excuse for any one of us because God has
given us sufficient evidence for
everything that we need to know look at
Romans 1:20 says that that God's
attributes are clearly seen through the
things he has made so that nobody is
without excuse and then Romans 2 verse4
and 15 says that even those who don't
have the law of God who don't have the
testimonies that they can read they
still have their conscience bearing
witness against them so I want to take
you to one other text here that explains
this very nicely it's Ezekiel 33 veres
1-9 and I'm only going to read verses 7
n here so Ezekiel 33:7 to9 so you son of
man I have made you a Watchman for the
house of Israel therefore you shall hear
a word from my mouth and warn them for
me when I say to the wicked oh Wicked
Man you shall surely die and you do not
speak to warn the wicked from his way
that Wicked man shall die in his
iniquity but his blood I will require at
your hand nevertheless if you warn the
wicked to turn from his way and he does
not turn from his way he shall die in
his iniquity but you have delivered your
soul so notice here you've got the
Watchman and he hears a word from God
and so he has more light than everybody
else if he does not warn the wicked and
the wicked die the wicked are still
going to have the consequence which is
death but their blood will also be
required at the hand of the Watchman who
had more more light he's going to Bear
the consequence of failing to live up to
the light that God gave him so the
ultimate consequence for everybody is
going to be the same it will be Eternal
death completely consumed by the fire of
God's presence when they no longer
shielded by God's mercy but the greater
light that you have rejected then the
greater will be your accountability and
the greater will be your suffering what
is that suffering let's leave it at this
I don't want to find out and neither do
you this is true all right but but what
we know is that God is fair uh because
of their willful contempt some are going
to Bear the consequence of their own sin
along with what they caused others to
commit as well so the message here is
that God is fair and I want to leave you
with this text in Isaiah 59: 18 this is
God's word according to their deeds
accordingly he will repay Fury to his
adversaries recompense to his enemies so
God weighs the heart the consequence
ultimately will be the same but some
will bear a greater accountability
because of the greater light that they
have received and rejected That's Heavy
thank you Daniel choose today to follow
Jesus absolutely as we speak of sin and
its consequences we're coming to Pastor
John deny and this is another question
pertaining to sin this came from Melinda
she sent a text in from Michigan Mary
the mother of Jesus was a sinner how
could Jesus be without sin if he was
born the son of a sinner that's a very
good question and
I want to start by saying that it is a
mystery that the Creator the Son of God
God himself would become or became a
human being now in Luke chap 1 verse 34
and
35 uh you see an angel talking to Mary
and notice what it says in verse 34 then
said Mary unto the angel how shall this
be seeing know not a man and the angel
answered and said unto her the Holy
Ghost shall come upon thee and the power
of the highest shall overshadow thee
therefore also that Holy thing which
shall be born of thee shall be called
The Son of God now I want to say here it
says that Holy thing but it's that Holy
One is what it should be uh said there
that Holy One which shall be born of the
shall be called The Son of God and this
is the mystery part yes Mary was a
sinner and uh that may sound shocking to
some people uh because of some beliefs
that she was not a sinner but Mary was a
sinner she also needed a savior and so
this you can find this very easily for
all have sin and come short of the glory
of God as it says in the Book of Romans
so because of the involvement the
process by which Jesus came into this
world became a babe uh uh there is this
this uh separate separateness if you
want to call it this is that a word
separateness sounds
good of Jesus be between him and us
Jesus did inherit from Mary certain
effects of sin because Jesus was born
into this world about about 4,000 years
of existence of the human race having
sin upon them so if you compare him with
Adam let's say Adam and Jesus in height
you could see there's a difference and
how sin has affected the human race so
Jesus became tired he became hungry he
was a human being but the Bible outlines
that he was holy so let's go to Hebrews
chapter 7 verse 26 talking about Jesus
it says for such a high priest became us
who is Holy harmless
undefiled separate from Sinners this is
where I get the word separateness from
separate from Sinners and made higher
than the heavens this is Jesus you see
Jesus was uh as well in all points
tempted like as we are yet without sin
notice what Peter says in 1 Peter
chapter 2 verse 22 uh let's begin in
verse 21 for to this you were called
because Christ also suffered for us
leaving us an example that you should
follow his steps who committed no sin
nor was deceit found in his mouth so we
have uh Peter that was with Jesus for at
least three and a half years he says he
committed no sin uh nor was any deceit
found in his mouth so you have this
testimony you have uh here in of course
in Hebrews chapter 7: 26 that he was
holy harmless undefiled how could this
be it is a mystery that only God can
reveal and we will have time in heaven
to ask all of these questions and get
clearness because the Bible only gives
us so much information there's so much
to learn and please understand that even
though he Jesus was born into this world
through a a vessel that was a sinner
Mary he will still remain he will still
remain wholly harmless and undefiled
amen thank you so much um powerful we're
going to Professor parin next and it's
interesting to me we're just talking
about the humanity of Jus now we're
talking about the Divinity of Jesus so
this came in a text question can you
prove that Jesus is God from the Bible
okay I love this question and I have
more notes here than I will have time to
share so this maybe will be part one of
a two-part response I don't know but I
want to start with what Jesus said to
pilate when pilate asked him if he was a
king in John
18:37 Jesus says that he came to not to
prove but to Bear Witness
to the truth now I can't prove anything
what I am authorized to do is to give
the evidence that God has shared with us
through the witness of his word and we
are invited to trust that witness you're
always going to have to take a step of
Faith but it's not blind faith based on
the evidence God gives us so assuming
that you already trust the words of the
Bible I'm going to take you to a couple
of statements in the Old Testament God
Jesus was recognized as God by Isaiah in
this verse Isaiah 9:6 listen to these
words now this is written by a
monotheistic Jew this is Isaiah who says
For unto us all right unto us humans a
child is born and unto us humans a son
is given and the government will be upon
his shoulder and his name will be called
wonderful counselor Mighty God that word
there is El gior it's the same name that
is used the next chapter in Isaiah 10:21
referring to Yahweh this is the son born
to us elgore Mighty God and then
Everlasting father uh this means is
identifying his eternal Reign his
eternal Kingdom so here's a statement
referring to Jesus Hebrews chapter 1:8
quotes Psalm 45:6 listen to these words
in hebrews: 18 but to the son he says
your throne oh God is forever and ever
so there's some testimony right there uh
what about Jesus statements why should
we believe that he is God if he didn't
believe that he was God well let's see
some of the things that Jesus said John
14 ver1 says you believe in God believe
also in me John 13: 19 Jesus says now I
tell you before it comes talking about
Judas that when it comes to pass you may
believe that I am he oh there's so much
here John 17:5 in his prayer oh now and
now oh Father glorify me together with
yourself with the glory I had with you
before the world was what is Jesus
saying right there he believes knows
that he existed from eternity with the
Father John 10:3 I and my father are one
John 13:13 you call me teacher and Lord
and you say well for so I am John 14:6
I'm the way the truth and the life if
you've seen me you've seen the father
I'm the resurrection and the life my
kingdom is not of this world there's
those are all from John right there and
then in John 8:58 and 59 Jesus says to
them most assuredly I say to you before
Abraham was I am using the name of God
himself and and the Jews recognize this
as blasphemy you're a mere man claiming
to be God and they take up stones to
kill him right there Jesus forgives sins
Luke 5:20 uh he says all authority on
Heaven and Earth is given to me this is
the testimony that Jesus claims of
himself and why should we believe Jesus
testimony about himself it is his
resurrection and it is the testimony of
the scriptures uh the the prophetic word
of the scriptures pointing forward to
him and that's not what this answer is
all about to go through the prophecies
but Jesus fulfilled those things that
pointed and validated him what about
some other New Testament statements
Colossians 1: 13-6 not going to read
them here John 1: 1:3 Hebrews 1: 1:3 all
point to Jesus Jesus as the Creator amen
who was there in the beginning in
Hebrews says he's the heir of all things
who upholds all things by the word of
his power these are Divine statements on
Earth he was the word made flesh John
1:14 he was conceived not by human power
but by the Holy Spirit we just read that
heard that here Luke 1:35 he was
recognized by the father at his baptism
as my beloved Son in whom I'm well
pleased Jesus exercised divine power to
give life to the dead that's in John 11
with Lazarus how about 1 Timothy 3:16
without controversy in other words
without question describes that Jesus is
God manifested In the Flesh there's the
quote right there Jesus is the Lamb of
God who in Revelation 321 sits on the
father's Throne Jesus sits on the
father's Throne he is God himself and
then finally here leave you with
Revelation 22: 12 to 21 some pieces from
there the reward of the righteous is
called Jesus reward and the Commandments
that are obeyed are Jesus Commandments
he is the alpha the Omega the first the
last the beginning and the end and the
final verse of the Bible says that Grace
belongs to Jesus it is Jesus Grace his
power all the way through from start to
finish amen that makes me want to shout
praise the Lord amen there's so much the
scriptures are rich with the proof the
evidence as you said I like that word
that Jesus is divine absolutely I just
want to remind you before we go to the
next question with Pastor John deny that
we would love to take your questions on
an upcoming Bible Q&A program um our
panel is study and prepare and want to
share from the word so that you can
learn more and study so feel free to
text us at 6182280065
5 you can email us at Bible qa3
abn.com Bible Q&A program Pastor Johnny
we're coming to you and this question
has to do with the validity of the
seventh day Sabbath and whether it's
still um in force or applicable to us
today this came from Kellen who sent in
an email I have heard and read that we
no longer need to remember or observe
the seventh day Sabbath rest since Jesus
died for us he has become our rest what
does this mean what scriptural evidence
are they using to support this claim
that we don't need to remember the
Sabbath
anymore thank you Kellen for that
question and I I don't think I've ever
used this uh this phrase before but I
think I would say it now nothing could
be further from the truth as far as uh
this idea being presented to you and it
is true it's happening today that every
wind of Doctrine is blowing now you said
you've heard and read so we have to be
careful with what we hear and read and
compare that with God's holy word there
is no scriptural evidence for this claim
you can search the Bible from Genesis to
Revelation and see that there is no
scriptural evidence for this claim this
is an unfortunate conclusion that some
people have come to but it's not based
on the scriptures let's go to Matthew
chapter 24 I'm going to begin reading in
verse 15 to get a little context to what
Jesus is saying you may remember that
Matthew chapter 24 uh there the
disciples asked Jesus about the
destruction of Jerusalem and the end of
the world and Jesus now begins to tell
them in verse uh 15 therefore when you
see the abomination of desolation spoken
of by Daniel the Prophet standing in the
Holy Place whoever reads let him
understand then let those who are in
Judea flee to the mountains let him who
is on the housetop not go down to take
anything out of his house and let him
who is in the field not go back to get
his clothes but woe to those who are
pregnant and uh and to those who are
nursing babies in those days and pray
that your flight may not be in the
winter or on the Sabbath pray that your
flight your Escape is not in the winter
or on the Sabbath for then there will be
Great Tribulation such as has not been
since the beginning of the world until
this time no nor ever shall be Jesus is
talking about the destruction of
Jerusalem and he is saying pray that
your Escape is not in the winter or on
the Sabbath why is Jesus telling his
disciples that they should pray that
their escape from Jerusalem is not on
the Sabbath if the Sabbath is already
done away with you see the Sabbath has
not been done away with the Sabbath
remains a Commandment that that God's
people need to keep because the Sabbath
is a sign between God and his people the
Sabbath is a a commemoration that he is
our creator had the world understood
this there would not be uh atheist
existing because everyone would
understand that God created the heavens
and the Earth and no question would
there be concerning that so when did
this happen when did the destruction of
Jerusalem take place that Jesus warned
them about pray that your Escape is not
on the Sabbath this was in 70 AD in 70
AD Jesus expected his followers to still
be keeping the Sabbath and Jesus expects
us to still be keeping the Sabbath when
did this sabbath idea begin I take you
to Genesis chapter 2 verse 1 and 2 and 3
notice what it says there thus the
heavens and the Earth and all the host
of them were finished and on the seventh
day God create God ended his work which
he had done and he rested on the seventh
day from all his work which he had done
this is Saturday and it says then God
blessed the seventh day and Sanctified
it because in it he rested from all his
work which God had created and made you
can look in Exodus chapter 20 verses 8-
11 and see there that God said remember
the Sabbath day to keep it holy uh so
that's homework for you now why did I
read Genesis chapter 2 beginning in
verse one and verse two and three well
because at this time uh there was no Jew
and people sometimes get the idea that
the Sabbath is only for the Jews no the
Sabbath was made for the human race amen
so I ask you had sin not entered into
the world what would God's children be
doing all the way from creation keeping
the seventh day Sabbath holy and resting
in it as God did from all his work so
this is what we understand from this so
there is no scriptural evidence for this
claim and um
I say to you when you hear things like
this when you read things like this go
to the scriptures and get a thus saith
the Lord so again there is no scriptural
evidence ah I I do have one more verse
to read to you and that is found in
Revelation chap 12 chapter 12 and then
verse 17 and the dragon which is the
devil was enraged with the woman and he
went to make war with the rest of her
Offspring who keep the Commandments of
God and have the testimony of Jesus
Christ so yes we should still be keeping
the Sabbath day this is why the devil is
going after God's people who keep the
Commandments of God thank you so much
Pastor Johnny that's excellent there's
so many confusing Winds of doctrine that
are blowing around right now and Daniel
we're coming to you and this is having
to do with making sure we study and know
what the truth is as well this is from
Dan he sent it in Via Instagram from
AUST Australia as I look for divine
ground to stand and build my belief on I
get confused as I look into other
religions and practices I was born and
raised an Adventist and as you grow up
you start asking yourself how all these
religions come to exist I've watched a
little about Judaism as and Islam
religions and it seems the players are
similar but with different names and
curricula could this be the works of
Satan to deceive me or could my
intuition be right or all religions the
same okay all right now Dan your name
means the judge I just want to to remind
you to judge rightly based upon God's
word and uh our intuitions may be right
but we always want to submit them to the
word of God here so let me give you an
answer and I could answer this in a
variety of different ways perhaps but
the children of Israel who grew up in in
the traditions of Israel that God gave
they asked the same question why why do
the sidonians worship ashth and why do
the moabites worship kamos and why do
why do the Philistines worship deeon or
or Marduk or Bale or or any of those
other gods there is there any legitimacy
or are we being deceived by those other
beliefs that are all around us now I am
an example of one of those who grew up
as a seventh a avenus Christian all the
structures of religious belief and
practice were in place for me but there
comes a point in your growing up years
at which you have to choose to inhabit
that structure of those beliefs and
practices and you may look around and
say I I kind of want to remodel what's
here here and so you start looking at
other faiths and beliefs and say well
why why not that belief well well they
believe in Morality too are are all
religions kind of the same is everything
that I've been taught really true as
I've understood it and it is important
to look and understand other faiths for
two reasons one so we can be
compassionate and understanding for
those with different beliefs and then so
that we can learn how best to share the
lifegiving truths that transform our
lives in other words there's something
to be said for being familiar with other
revered writings like the Quran or the
Bhagavad Gita or the dhap or other other
other things there's lots of stuff out
there but studying those books will not
get you to the truth and the enemy of
righteousness knows this God has a
perfect way and so Satan prompts men's
Minds to imagine a counterfeit a similar
counterfeit and that's what we discover
there are similar moral codes in almost
all the world's religion
don't kill care for the poor and needy
respect and care for your parents almost
all the things that we as Christians say
this is what we ought to live others say
the very same thing they might do it for
different reasons like reciprocity or
fairness or Karma or or obedience or
something like that we also discover
that other religious Traditions have
similar Traditions they give offerings
they have prayers they have music and
this leads people to believe are all
roads really leading up the mountain
well you discover that what Waits them
at the top of the mountain is very very
different it's not the same Mountain all
roads diverge over the issue of Jesus's
claim in John 14:6 and other places I am
the way not a way the truth and the life
no one comes to the father through any
other means but through me this does not
mean that only professed Christians will
be saved in fact many of them will not
but anyone who is saved will not be
saved because of their religious affili
they will be saved because of Jesus and
not everybody hears the name of Jesus
but remember that conscience in Romans
2:14 there're in the heart and I want
you to listen to How how Satan then
manipulates this Genesis 3:4 the serpent
says to the woman we got a true thing
that God said in re in in uh in Genesis
2 don't eat of that tree or you're going
to die and the serpent says you will not
surely die diverging paths you got two
paths here Isaiah 536 then tells us more
all we like sheep have gone astray we
have turned everyone to his own way yeah
and so each person does what they want
to do and now we have another way
another path another Viewpoint
ultimately Deuteronomy 32:17 says what
happens here they sacrificed to Demons
not to God to gods they did not know to
New Gods new arrivals that their fathers
did not fear ultimately when we follow
our own way this is Satan's this is
Satan's idea here let's give them many
other paths make them all all look good
and then they'll begin to say all paths
are right but the truth always comes
back to Jesus is he who he said he was
come back to the scriptures I could say
more but we'll stop there thank you so
much Daniel we're coming to Pastor
Johnny now this came in from Audra from
Georgia via text acts 12:4 mentions the
word Easter is this the same Easter that
people observe
today
no the quick short answer is no uh let
me go ahead and read acts
12:4 and when he had apprehended him he
put him in prison and delivered him to
four Quan quarians of soldiers to keep
him intending after Easter to bring him
forth to the people so this is a the
only place in the King James version
where you will find the word Easter
unfortunately this is a sad translation
uh please understand that this is when
you look at the Greek is the Hebrew I
mean the Greek word that orig that came
from the c word uh pasca which is
referring to the Passover yes uh what
you call Easter today was not observed
during the time uh that we have here in
the scriptures in the book of Acts
so uh 29 times the word pasca is found
in the new Testament and 28 times it is
translated Passover this is the only
place where you will find the word
Easter and unfortunately it it got into
the King James
version uh influence of the people of
the day but if you stay true through
what is the uh actual translation is the
word Passover that should be here and
you can see here that this this is
talking about a time when the Passover
was observed by the Jews so this is not
talking about what people call Easter
today and so what can we say to you uh
you can look in the britanica for
example I have here uh some words
concerning this the English word Easter
which parallels the German word ostern
is of Uncertain origin one view
expounded by the venerable bead in the
8th century was that it derived from
eostre orost the Anglo-Saxon goddess of
spring and fertility and if you look
into this a little deeper you'll find
that this idea of Easter is connected to
the veral Equinox now um if it's it if
it is indeed following the resurrection
of Christ why isn't there a specific
date for this you see that Easter falls
on the say according to the Catholic
church is the one that selects the date
by the way they select the date for
Easter and it is not it is not the
Passover like the Passover of those days
that uh the Jews were keeping and the
Jews still keep Passover today a little
different because of the situation now
no Tempo Etc but let me read to you a
couple of scriptures where the word the
same word pasca is used but the word
Passover is used in Matthew 26 verse 1
and2 it says now it came to pass when
Jesus had finished all these say that he
said to his disciples you know that
after two days is the Passover and the
son of man will be delivered up to be
crucified this is the same word pasca
why wasn't the word Easter put there
because it is obviously not a practice
that was done in those days so in First
Corinthians
5:7 therefore Purge out the old leaven
that you may be a new lump since you
truly are unleavened for indeed Christ
Our Passover was sacrificed for us now
if you were to take the same idea in
Acts chapter 124 you would have to say
for Christ Our Easter was sacrificed for
us it doesn't make sense you see so it's
the word Passover that should be there
in Acts 12:4 you can compare with other
translations of the Bible for example
the new King James uses the word
Passover and many other translations
this is why it's good to compare
different translations and you can see
that uh you can find Clarity by
comparing these things and looking into
the the dictionaries that are available
the strongs is something readily
available for everybody and you can see
that the word pasca is actually the word
in Acts chap 12 verse four which means
Passover thank you so much Pastor Johnny
it's so important to be able to do that
word study and see what actually the
original says as well that's powerful uh
Daniel coming to you this came in from
Adam um he's from Alaska and he sent in
an email how do we know that the water
Jesus turned into wine was not fermented
all right I love that the word of God is
Con istent because God does not change
and it's clear so let me answer your
question with two Bible texts and then
I'll give you some more the first one is
Luke 9 verse 56 for the son of man did
not come to destroy men's
lives but to save them right that's the
first one and then the second one is
John 10:10 the thief does not come
except to steal and to kill and destroy
I have come that they may have life that
they may have it more abundantly now
when Jesus cre created the world did he
give Adam and Eve fresh fruit to taste
or rotten fruit fresh fruit to taste
when the same Jesus created that wine
there uh did he stumble and fail in the
process uh had he lost his touch over
the past 4,000 years or did he as the
Bible says do all things well creating
perfect fresh vibrant delicious tasty
juice fresh from the fruit now listen to
the testimony from God's word and this
is this is Jesus's word right here
listen to these things and Jesus always
acts in agreement with his word Proverbs
23: 29 and 30 and there's more to the
text here who has woe who has sorrow and
then skipping to verse 30 those who go
in search of mixed wine Isaiah 5:22 woe
to Mighty Men at drinking wine woe to
men Valiant for mixing intoxicating
drink is Jesus going to mix intoxicating
drink that he says woe to Isaiah 28:7
but they priests and Prophets who are
drunk also have aired through wine and
through intoxicating drink are out of
the way is Jesus going to give people
something that will lead them into error
out of the way Proverbs 20:1 wine is a
mocker strong drink is a brawler and
whoever is Led astray by it is not wise
is Jesus going to lead people in a way
that is not wise habach 2:14 and
remember this is inspired by Jesus
Through the Holy Spirit go to him who
gives drink to his neighbor pressing him
to your bottle is Jesus going to do that
Proverbs 31:4 it is not for Kings to
drink wine what was Jesus he was a king
now with Jesus who does all things well
who cares about life and salvation who
came to save and inspired the the
written testimony of the scriptures that
we've just look through just a a few of
them right there would he give something
to drink that clouds the Mind inhibits
moral decision-making leads to addiction
devastates Financial Security breaks
apart families degenerates the taste of
the fresh juice leads to sinful and
destructive decisions and habits causes
others to stumble and makes them drunk
with which he himself had forbidden
would he give that absolutely not that's
why James 1 ver7 says every good gift
and every perfect gift not every
degraded rotten deadly gift every good
and perfect gift comes from above comes
down from the Father of Lights with whom
there is no variations or shadow of
turning Isaiah 65:8 says this thus says
the Lord as the new wine and Jesus made
new wine it was right there made before
there before them new wine is found in
the cluster in other words it's fresh
it's come out undegraded unfermented no
rotting and one sayso not destroy it for
there's a blessing in it Satan is a
Deceiver he is a counterfeit and he
counterfeits every good thing God makes
Jesus does not deal in
counterfeits thank you so much Dan
that's powerful praise the Lord we're
coming down to the end of the program we
have two questions left we're going to
try to get them both in here Pastor
Johnny your last question this is kind
of an obscure Bible verse it the
question came in via email can you
please explain Leviticus 27 verse 31
thank you so much this is a very
interesting question so here in
Leviticus I'm going to start reading in
verse uh 28 Leviticus chapter 27: 28 and
then onward nevertheless no devoted
offering that a man May devote to the
Lord of all that he has both man and
Beast or the field of his possession
shall be sold or redeemed every devoted
offering is most holy to the Lord no
person under the ban who may become
doomed to destruction among men shall be
redeemed but shall surely be put to
death and it says verse 30 and all the
tithe of the land whether of the seed of
the land or of the fruit of the tree is
the Lord's it is Holy to the
Lord if a man wants to once at all to
redeem any other tithes he shall add one
to it that is the verse in question so
this is talking about the seed and fruit
of the tree if you want to redeem it
let's say for example oh man I need some
seeds I need to I need to get seeds so
you can either buy it from someone but
if you say man I like the seeds I have
and you decide to take of these seeds
then the Lord says you add a fifth to
it this fifth to it is like 20% so it
was to deter people from actually
wanting to redeem things now what would
happen is that they would evaluate the
fruit and say well today this is worth x
amount and they would take money and pay
that money and add a fifth to it now
some people look at this text and say
man I'm really low on cash this month I
really need to take the tithe and I'll
add a fifth to it now this is a
dangerous thinking and this is not what
the Bible is teaching so as far as
you're tithe the 10% that you're it
belongs to the Lord to say I'm going to
take it and buy me a car I'm going to
take it and pay the rent I'm going to
take it and do this if you're having
trouble with your Finance it's time to
step back analyze your expenses and say
man maybe I don't need this subscription
and this subscription and this
subscription and do away with this uh so
that you don't have such pressure in
your home to uh return the Lord's tithe
so take a look at your finances ask God
for wisdom as to what can be cut of
expenses maybe instead of going out to
eat every week three or four times a
week maybe you need to cut that down but
cut down your expenses so you're not
tempted to say I'm going to keep the
tithe and so I
remember I I remember uh many people
that have told stories of thinking even
Danny remember telling him a story
thinking the same thing boy I really got
to pay this and pay that and uh uh here
comes the plate it was getting closer
and closer he had to make a decision do
I keep the tithe so I can pay my bills
or do I uh put the money in and trust
the Lord will he decided to trust in the
Lord and if you'll hear Danny tell the
story uh he will tell you that the Lord
blessed that week money came to him
unexpect unexpectedly and be faithful to
God and he as the Bible says will pour
out a blessing that there will not be
room enough to contain it so be faithful
to the Lord don't fall into these traps
of keeping the tithe thinking I'm going
to pay the Lord later it is dangerous
thank you Pastor Johnny our God is
faithful last question here for
Professor parin this came from Renee who
lives in New York she sent it in Via
Instagram why do they call Jesus the son
of David all right good question Renee
thank you for sending it in there is
both a carnal or physical reality and a
spiritual reality we want to we want to
keep them both in in the right context
so the physical reality is that the word
son of not only means dad and son but it
means descendant all right so Jesus was
a physical literal descendant of David
both Matthew chapter 1 and Luke chapter
three in their genealogies Trace Jesus
ancestry through David so he was a
literal descendant of son of David but
there's more to that David wanted to
build a temple for the Lord God and so
in response God gave to David a covenant
and in the Covenant we're going to read
this in 2 Samuel 7: 12-6 we're going to
find this Covenant 2 Samuel 71 12-6 God
speaking to David when your days are
fulfilled you will rest with your father
fathers I will set up your seed after
you all right that'd be a descendant who
will come from your body and I will
establish his kingdom he shall build a
house for my name and he will establish
the Throne of his kingdom forever this
was originally initially fulfilled
through Solomon but listen to God's
saying more here I will be his father
and he shall be my son if he commits
iniquity I will chasen him with the rod
of men and with the blows of the sons of
men but my Mercy shall not depart from
him as I took it from Saul whom I
removed from before you and your house
that would be the the physical line of
descendants and your kingdom right
that's the rulership shall be
established how long does it say forever
forever your throne shall be established
forever so you got this fatherson
relationship and you have both the line
and the kingdom extending forever first
fulfilled through Solomon but then the
prophets begin to pick up on this and
say even after Solomon we're looking
forward to something more listen to
Isaiah 11 one there shall come forth a
rod that's a ruler from the stem of
Jesse Jesse is David's father and a
branch shall grow out of his roots
Jeremiah 23:5 and 6 says behold the days
are coming says the Lord that I will
raise to David a branch of righteousness
a king shall reign and prosper and
execute judgment skipping down to the
end of verse six His Name by which he
will be called the Lord our
righteousness this is not a human that
he's referring to uh Jeremiah 33:17 says
David shall never lack a man to sit on
the throne of the House of Israel this
was not fulfilled by humans looking
forward to a Big King the real King
which is there there's a number of texts
we see this fulfilled in the New
Testament but I want to take you just to
the Luke 1: 32 and 33 Gabriel is coming
down announcing to Mary what's going to
happen as she's going to have a baby
says that he will be great and will be
called the son of the highest and the
Lord God will give him the Throne of his
father David so Jesus is the son of
David which means he is the Eternal King
the Divine ruler the divinely anointed
Messiah who is also our savior from sin
amen thank you so much Daniel and Pastor
Johnny for your study of the word we
want to give you an opportunity to send
in your questions we want to take them
and answer them on an upcoming Bible Q&A
program you're important to us you are
part of the 3bn family no question
question is too um insignificant just
whatever's on your heart feel free to
send that in because we want to answer
them on an upcoming program so here's
how you can do just that and then we'll
be back on the other side with some
closing thoughts for
you if you're enjoying our 3abn Bible
Q&A then tell your friends each Monday
we'll bring you a fresh program
answering the Bible questions you send
us using God's holy word to shed light
on the those texts that seem difficult
to understand to have your questions
answered on a future program just email
them to us at bible QA 3abn.org
[Music]
from God's word welcome back we're so
glad that you've spent this hour with us
as we opened up the word of God and
studied together I want to give each one
of our panelists here our family
opportunity to share a closing thought
Daniel we'll start with you yes you know
I I talked about Satan introducing new
ideas and beliefs that diverge over
Jesus and I just want to share with you
the example here of back in the Garden
of Eden where in Genesis 3:15 God says
to Adam and Eve that the seed of the
woman will come and will be the one who
will crush the head of the serpent to
destroy sin but he's going to he's going
to be uh bitten himself he's going to be
uh be uh his heel will be crushed and so
Satan then prompts the hearts of evil
men to say ah a son will be sacrificed
sacrifice your own sons and so people
started to do that and this is Satan's
way and I want you to notice once again
the Divergence is over Jesus Satan is
always going to try to give us through
through other men's ideas different
ideas that will lead us away from
salvation through Christ to put our
faith in ourselves amen Pastor Johnny so
I uh I want to leave this with you
because of the idea of Jesus uh having
sin or not sin upon him because of
coming through Mary he was holy
blameless and undefiled I read to you
from 1 Peter chapter 1: 18 knowing that
you were not redeemed with corruptible
things like silver or gold from your
aimless conduct received by tradition
from your fathers but with the precious
blood of Christ as of a lamb without
blemish and without spot because he was
wholly blameless and undefiled Jesus was
the perfect sacrifice that could redeem
us from destruction and we can have
salvation through him amen thank you so
much Pastor Johnny and Daniel thank you
for your study of the word and being
here today we thank you for joining us
as well I'm reminded of Jeremiah 24 it
says I will give them a heart to know me
that I am the Lord so I just want to
encourage you to open up your heart ask
God that he will reveal himself to you
through his word we'll see you next time
[Music]